what up guys welcome to the just hurry
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way and
let's get started today I am going to be
reacting to Ben Shapiro's best clip of
all time one of the best um as you know
I'm a conservative so I did grow up
watching Ben Shapiro one of my favorite
content creators and probably one of the
reasons that I'm conservative King pull
up the clip I'm John's my next guest how
strong was for me says I'm off the rails
on guns in America Ben Shapiro is editor
at large at breitbart.com and you also
love this
intimidation silences Americans so why
am I off the rails Mr Shapiro uh you
know honestly Pierce you've kind of been
a bully on this issue because what you
do and I've seen it repeatedly on your
show I watch your show um and I've seen
it repeatedly what you tend to do is you
tend to demonize people who differ from
you politically by standing on the
graves of the children of Sandy Hook
saying they don't seem to care enough
about the dead kids if they cared more
about the dead kids they would agree
with you on policy I think
ballsy is this just as a media person I
think of how ballsy it is to go on like
Attack Mode on someone else's show I
have a rational political conversation
about balancing rights and risks and
rewards of all of these different
policies but I don't think that what we
need to do is demonize people on the
other side is as being unfeeling about
the about what happened yeah you accuse
me of standing on the grades of the
children that died there how dare you
I've seen you do it repeatedly Pierce
like I say how dare you I mean you can
keep saying that but you've done it
repeatedly with what you do and I've
seen you do it on the program is you
keep saying to folks that if they
disagree with you politically then
somehow this is a violation of of what
happened in Sandy Hook and you have yet
I I really like to hear your policy
prescriptions for what we should do
about guns because you say that you
respect the Second Amendment and you
know I brought this here for you so that
you can read it it's the Constitution
and I
this is the most goaded thing he has
ever done this footbed disappear on the
map you don't understand okay you know
how there's like guys like corn or
whatever this is like conservative corn
now please don't take this out of
context I don't mean it like that but I
just mean like when conservatives and we
think of like pivotal moments in the
last 10 years in conservative media this
this I would really like for you to
explain to me what you would do about
guns that would have prevented what
happened in Sandy Hook if you want to do
what you did in the UK right which is
banned virtually all guns that is at
least a fair argument and we can have a
discussion about whether that's
something that we ought to do I made it
very clear what I want to do which is
exactly what Mark Kelly wants to do and
in fact bring back the guns I'm in the
UK bring them back look if I call the
cops here and they bring me someone with
no guns then address let's talk about
that rather than address your comments
to me about uh standing on the graves of
children at Sandy Hook you can address
them to Mark Kelly because he agrees
with everything that I've been saying
because he feels the same way as does
his wife they're gun owners they both
despite the Second Amendment of the
Constitution they don't want to take
away anybody's right to defend
themselves with guns they want to take
away certain types of guns they want to
take away assault weapons which are
capable with magazines that we saw at
Aurora and Sandy Hook of unleashing a
ridiculous amount well this is a
question I wanted to ask you pierce
because I've seen you I've seen you talk
about assault weapons a lot and I've
seen Mark Kelly talk about assault
weapons the vast majority of murders in
this country that are committed with
guns are not committed with the saw
weapons they're committed with handguns
okay are you willing to ban handguns in
this country across no that's not what
I'm asking for why not let me ask you
don't you care about the kids who are
being killed in Chicago as much as the
kids in San Diego yes I do then why
don't you care about about them I'd like
you see
handguns in Chicago no we'll come to
that let me ask you this let me ask you
this what was the weapon used in Aurora
in the movie theater it was in yeah it
was it was an assault rifle sure okay
what was the weapon used in the Oregon
Shopping Mall yeah I believe it's an
assault rifle correctly what was the
weapon used at Sandy Hook isn't assault
rifle what was the weapon used the
incident around Christmas when the
fireman were to their deaths the New
York State Farm and bought illegally
that was it that was it that was an
assault so the last four mass shootings
in America were all this all right and
the vastness is the reason Mr Shapiro
and you can smirk at me and you can
laugh at me and you can accuse me of
standing on the graves of dead children
he's so calm the reason that people like
me and Mark Kelly and Gabrielle Giffords
want to have assault weapons like that
removed from civilian hands your passion
on the issue doesn't really justify the
rationale for why you want to ban
assault weapons that's why we want to
remove the preferred weapon of choice uh
these killing machines
all I'm asking is for you to be
philosophically consistent if what
you're worried about is the removal of
killing machines from the hands of
deranged young people then maybe we
should talk about a blanket gun ban and
let's get to what the left really wants
here and the you know you say that
you're fine left or right because in
Britain this never is about left or
right this issue why is it here well you
know we can talk about Britain in a
second I think the reason that it's
about left and right here is because
fundamentally the right believes that
the basis for the Second Amendment and
they believe in the Second Amendment the
basis for the Second Amendment is not
really about self-defense and it's not
about hunting it is about resistance to
government tyranny and this is what
British people don't understand okay
British I've explained this to so many
British people that our right to guns is
to protect practice from the government
it is not about protecting I mean you
know protecting us from each other
that's another whole nother thing but
it's literally to protect us from the
government and the other thing they
don't understand think about it
a criminal's gonna get a gun anyway I've
had people in England tell me they can
get guns I don't know you know but it's
like so if you ban guns then only the
people that get them illegally can now
get guns not really fair and the other
thing is that this doesn't affect rich
people because rich people can afford
security where people that are poor or
can't so it's like
yeah that's what the founder said and
that's what the right beliefs in this
country are you fearing yourself I
feared the possibility of attorney
rising in this country in the next 50 to
100 years let me tell you something
cares the fact that my grandparents and
great grandparents in Europe didn't fear
that is why they are now ashes in Europe
so this this kind of leftist revision is
history where there's never any fear of
democracy going usurpatious or
tyrannical is just to clarify your
position then the answer to Sandy Hook
as it was to Aurora as it was to
Gabrielle givers as it was to Columbine
Virginia Tech is you do nothing is that
your position and that's not my position
my position is that we have to calibrate
laws that are designed to get hands out
guns out of the hands of bad people and
keep guns in the hands of good people
who want to buy them
how do you do that well I think one of
the ways that you do that is by better
screening for mental illness I think
that you do better background checks was
Adam Lanza's mother a good person uh I
don't know whether she was a good person
or a bad person irresponsible with her
guns has there been any evidence to
suggest she was not a good person no but
there's been a significant
wait a minute by your criteria of the
good people should be allowed the guns
and the bad people shouldn't she would
have been allowed the guns she was an
irresponsible person she didn't keep her
guns locked up and that and that should
be against it you have a mentally ill
person in your house we're talking about
laws that we can both agree
ah bad bad please come back to debate
please please guys everyone please go to
Ben Shapiro's page I miss you dunking on
college kids let me put you on a panel
with some crazy women please please then
she becomes a bad person does she well
no it's not a matter of it's not a
matter of morally criteria good and bad
so is she good or bad you're right
Pierce I should have said responsible
versus irreponsible that's correct okay
so she goes from good to bad no she goes
from responsible to get responsible
let's take a break let's come back and
talk more about this because we don't
agree
can you imagine what that break was like
oh my gosh Ben Shapiro knew that he just
made his career
Who's Live or not
I mean I was Ben Shapiro editor at large
at breitbart.com and the author of
bullies do you believe that uh if you
had an assault weapon ban statistics
prove that you could dry up the supply
of these guns and make unless accessible
to criminals
um I don't know whether you could make
them less accessible to criminals let's
assume that's the case that you could
make them less accessible to criminals
again my question remains for your peers
and I'm still waiting for an answer from
the left on this they say the pro-second
amendment why don't you want to ban
handguns if you really want to solve the
quote-unquote gun violence problem in
America go after all the guns why just
stop yourself at assault rifles because
I believe in respect an Americans right
under the Second Amendment of the
Constitution that you kindly brought in
to defend themselves with a handgun or a
pistol what I don't understand most of
the murders are committed with those
weapons well as we just established I
talked you through them the last four
mass shootings in America Two Pistols on
him he's just having assault rifle he
hadn't had the assault he didn't use
them as you know and if he and if he
hadn't had the assault rifle he wouldn't
have used them well and they don't talk
about all the times that crimes are
about to happen like there was a
shooting in a church in Texas one of the
guys went to his car grabbed a gun and
shot the dude in the face look it I
would be a lot more skeptical skeptical
to rob houses if I thought a lot of
people were armed I can't buy this this
is six packets of Sudafed one of the
many companies that make this particular
ingredient which you can't buy legally
in America there we are six Packers that
is illegal for me to buy in that
quantity in Walmart say but I can buy an
AR-15 military style assault rifle I can
then as we saw with Holmes the shooter
in Aurora going at six thousand years
voice yeah he's not he is not happy
rounds of ammunition from the internet
and I can go and blow up a movie theater
do you think that's right well we can
talk drug laws another time does that
make sense to you no I think what I
think what would make sense is laws that
are calibrated to solve the problem so
if you think that the problem is the
only assault right which guns would you
remove I would I think the ones that
have largely been removed from the
market fully automatic weapons would be
would be a good start
um I think that you wouldn't remove any
semi-automatics at all no because
semi-automatic just means that when you
pull the trigger runs one bullet comes
out you understand
essentially do you understand how AR-15
performance when it's been modified and
as a magazine starting in the North
Hollywood shootout you know what it was
illegal to do that and people did it
anyway we have we have 12 million
illegal immigrants in this country we're
not able to stop people people from
coming illegally into this country over
the southern border into places like
California where I live normally I I
think you'd be very hard-pressed to stop
guns from coming across that border
illegally as well I mean California has
some of the strictests do you want to be
American to have an AR-15 I know not
every American who would you stop I
would stop anyone with a criminal
background I would stop anybody with a
history of mental illness and I would
stop and I would ask it and not ask I
would require that people who have
somebody who has a criminal background
or a history of mental illness in the
household keep that gun locked up and
safe what about the background checks 40
of all uh gun sales in America now gun
trades are not covered by background I
believe in background checks for
everybody for everybody so there should
be a database a national register uh if
it's not public I don't like what
happened with The Journal News putting
out gun permits which allows criminals
to Target particular homes when the NRA
came out today after the meeting with
the White House and just said we're just
not prepared to entertain effectively
any kind of new gun restrictions what
did you think of that what's astonishing
to me is the left attack on the NRA
because the NRA is they don't receive a
dime of public dollars they're not
they're I want to know if there's a stat
on what percent of Shooters of School
shooters are from single mother homes I
don't know what it would be but someone
should look that up and send it to me
they're an interest group I don't see
you know it's funny the left they like
to talk also about violent video games
for example framing is left or right
because I don't have a horse in the race
vote either way oh come on peers you you
tend to be more to the left and y'all
understand NRA as you know are a very
active and well-funded and Powerful body
and what they do why are you asking I
just want to finish this let me finish
this very quick I promise the the point
that I'm making is this there's a lot of
been a lot of talk by a lot of people
that video game violence I haven't seen
David Gregory interviewing the head of
the ACLU and saying it's your broad
interpretation of the First Amendment
that's responsible for this but people
are bringing on the NRA and saying it's
your broad interpretation of the Second
Amendment that's responsible for this
they're an interest group if you want
legislation passed talk to Legends
members here's what the NRA and people
like Alex Jones and others do don't let
me in with Alex Jones after each of
these massacres they come out uh all the
gun rights supporters come up very
strongly and very vociferous
and they basically instill fear they say
if every one of them if everyone in the
movie theater had been armed everyone at
the school had been armed it wouldn't
have happened and here's what happens
gun sales and ammunition sales rocket as
we've seen in the last three weeks oh
don't pass the buck Piers I mean the
truth is that the reason doesn't happen
the reason that people are buying a lot
of guns right now peers is because
people on the left are talking very much
about banning guns and so a lot of
people are saying if I can't if I'm not
going to have the right to buy a
purchase away and guys let's look at how
London I live in London all right I hear
about stabbing here like I'm under the
impression I would rather be shot than
stabbed King in Nigeria do they have
guns like legal oh really mostly like
okay you can't just buy guns what about
you you think that guns depending on how
influence on money I think everyone
should be able to buy a gun or do you
think I'm wrong you can say it no
actually I actually agree but it's just
one thing to have actually like everyone
should be able to defend them yeah
unless no one has guns I I want a gun
I do I do my dad is a shooting range you
know yes yes and of my choosing in two
months I'm gonna go and buy it now this
is very clearly Reagan want these
assault weapons removed you know I don't
know why Ronald Reagan one of these are
you a bit of a you like Reagan right
away he's not a God I don't agree with
him on everything did you agree with him
yes I believe in the progressive tax
rate I don't believe in that did you
agree with about assault weapons um if
I'll believe what you're saying sure I I
don't believe it I don't know I don't
know what his position on assault
weapons was well let me read the letter
and sure there's a letter that he penned
a lot more presidents falling Carter in
1994 to Congress while we recognize that
assault weapon legislation will not stop
all assault weapon crime statistics
prove that we can dry out the supply of
these guns making them less accessible
to criminals we urge you to listen to
the American public and to the law
enforcement community and supportive ban
on the further manufacture of these
weapons that was Ronald Reagan yeah I
can disagree with Ronald Reagan you keep
framing for the left right
one of the great right-wing presidents
of modern times agreed with me so so
it's not left or right is it no I mean
it is
in a way that the NRA through the 80s
and 90s Pierce you're not even from
America you're not even from America and
America is left and right the right
wants guns the left doesn't like get out
of here I'm just lost
this as a left-wing attack on the
America because it is second
Constitution and the Second Amendment
I'm from Chicago we got a ton of gun
laws in Chicago do you know what Chicago
is known for violence and that's the
thing about people in the UK and I and
I'm only saying this because I live here
I live in the UK I'm from Chicago and
they all think they all think that you
could just ban guns in the U.S and it
would be the same as in the UK but what
you got to look at is one different
cultures respond to laws in different
ways so in one culture you might ban
guns and more people might listen than
not but Americans we are not known for
following the rule I mean our entire
country was made off of not following
the rules so it's like I don't I don't
think the we're gonna have the same
reaction that England did or that I
think Japan is the example that they use
because cultures are different and when
we ban guns these cities are horrible
you've tried to do you come in you
brandish your little book as if I don't
know my little book that's the
Constitution of the United States
[Laughter]
in your Constitution do you really I've
been debating this for a very long time
then you should read the second
amendment I know the same you should
read the Second Amendment oh he's so
funny I haven't heard is one coherent
reason why any civilian in America needs
an AR-15 military-style assault Elliot
tell me why you need one I told you why
why the general population of America
law-abiding citizens why do they need
those weapons they need them for the
prospective possibility of resistance to
tyranny which is not a concern today it
may not be a concerned to come from it
could come from the United States
because governments have gone to radical
before because
no it's not absurd okay you know how
absurd it sounds that they're putting
left dispropaganda in schools that
sounds crazy but it turns out to be true
in a lot of things that conservatives
whine about and sound crazy turn out to
be true so here's where you go into the
Absurd and the bullying you're absurd
you're stupid I understand
you of standing on the graves of dead
children because you're the one who's
doing that bullying
probably you know what I call it
punching back twice as hard in the in
the president That's What I Call
bullying astonishing what's astonishing
what's astonishing about it is that for
weeks now you have been saying that
anybody who disagrees with your position
is absurd idiotic and doesn't care about
the dead kids in Sandy Hook and then
when I say that that's a bully tactic
you turn around and say I'm bullying you
for saying that it's absurd it's
ridiculous
I don't care Ben Shapiro is goaded he is
so goaded let me ask you again what is
the point of a civilian having an AR-15
assault weapon the point of it a
civilian having an AR-15 assault weapon
many of them are ex-military right I
mean I have military friends and I have
no prob I don't have a problem with
Colin Powell owning an AR-15 assault
weapons
it depends on the civilian if it's a
criminal they shouldn't forget criminals
an average civilian average
why do they need one to project against
the possibility of eventual government
tyranny this was the purpose of the
Second Amendment originally it Remains
the purpose of the Second Amendment now
and pretending that governments have
never gone usurpatious before from a
democratic do you believe your own
government is going to turn on you in a
way that you require
15 to challenge them and you really
believe it may not turn on me
it may not turn on me may not turn on my
children but the fact is this history is
replete with democracies going
tyrannical it has happened it happened
in France in the 19th century it
happened in Spain in the last century it
happened in Germany it happened in Italy
and it's happened repeatedly happened in
Japan the reason we cannot remove AR-15
assault weapons is because the threat of
your own government turning on you in a
tyrannical way it is yes it is your
position it is because there are
countervailing rights and
responsibilities
you have made your point Crystal Clear
people aren't stupid they can make up
their own minds Ben Shapiro thank you
coded have you seen this before King
this is I'm telling you I don't know if
you don't even have your headphones on
this is what that's a shame because you
just miss one of the greatest clips of
all time in conservative media history
Pierce Morgan got humbled on his own
show do you know how hard it is to
Humble someone on their own show
oh oh oh oh that was so amazing anyways
guys let me know what you think in the
comments like the video
um and let me know uh what I want to do
some more like old school conservative
reactions so let me know what I should
react to subscribe I'll talk to you next
time